wouldn't it be nice for everyone to know  going into the job okay this person  right here actually is making a little  more because they have an extra skill  that I don't have one why don't I go out  and learn that extra skill so that I can  be price matched with what that other  person is that sounds nice and I think  if I was like an imp like when I was on  the other side I might have agreed but  like people just start to get entitled  and even though even if they're a whole  hell of a lot less productive like it's  night and day it's like people just have  this ego and it's like you can't even  even with the bad guy like everyone else  probably could have said she deserves  more money she's better but even even  when they have that like that's that's  not even just a guy thing like that's  just a human thing